i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday march 30th 2022 alisa brady
tax the rich makes a comeback in the
president's proposed budget but it's a
long way to the finish line and so i
think that although many of the
democrats want to change
taxation on wealthy individuals and
corporates i'm not so sure at this point
there are 50 votes to get there
i'm chris foster will smith hitting
chris rock strikes some other comedians
as a sign of the times we've had five
years of people treating jokes as hate
crimes this is why you have to defund
the joke police because there's a lot of
people out there who cannot distinguish
between someone making fun of you and
literally attacking you
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the nearly six trillion dollar budget
blueprint unveiled by president biden
this week brings back a familiar theme
now i'm a capitalist but uh just i want
i if you make a billion bucks great
just pay your fair share he's proposing
what he calls a billionaire minimum
income tax as part of an effort to spend
more on things like police health
education and defense while still
cutting deficits his plan would also
raise the top individual tax rate and
boosts the corporate tax rate to 28
percent republicans say if passed as is
it would be the largest tax hike in u.s
history i'd say the by administration as
well so many other people here in
washington d.c are just whistling past
the graveyard a 5.8 trillion dollar
budget wisconsin republican senator ron
johnson says he'd like to simplify the
country's tax system that's not what
this is going to be doing i think it'd
probably cause do more harm than good
the so-called billionaires tax would be
a 20 percent minimum on households worth
at least 100 million dollars but in
addition to income it would tax
unrealized gains in other words the
increased value of assets like property
or stocks or business we've had a lot of
wealth tax ideas this is another kind of
version of the wealth tax idea brian
brenberg is a professor of business and
economics at the king's college in new
york city and a fox news contributor and
there's just not enough bipartisan
support for it because we've seen these
ideas around the globe actually so this
was an idea this wealth tax that
europe a number of countries in europe
tried for several years and what's
happened is that most of those countries
have actually abandoned the idea because
practically it's so
difficult to execute actually that it
doesn't end up generating the revenue
that the politicians promise but what it
does is it drives the wealthy out of
those countries so i think it's just not
going to get the traction that the byte
administration hopes that it will is
part of the argument for that that
wealth creation um kind of goes in
tandem with
job creation with creating opportunities
yeah i mean that's exactly it you know
the entrepreneurs that build these
businesses that end up becoming worth a
lot of money that would be taxed
under this new plan those are people who
employ workers who get the labor market
the jobs part of the economy really
humming and so in a moment like this
especially i think there's very few
people out there who want to jeopardize
a jobs comeback and that's the real
concern if you're going to tax
not just income but actually wealth
creation the businesses that you build
the investments that you make before you
even sell them
the fear is that those job creators
aren't going to do that they're not
going to come to america to build those
businesses or if they're here they're
going to consider leaving it's going to
stunt all of that wealth creation that
turns into job creation that turns into
the kind of economy that actually works
for everybody
what about what democrats say about that
kind of argument that well that amounts
to trickle-down economics and that
doesn't work and that the wealthy aren't
paying their fair share
well i think the wealthy aren't paying
their fair share argument
doesn't ring true with the data that we
see when we look at
income tax for example and and what
percentage of income taxes collected
that the top 1 to the top 10 percent pay
relative to how much they earn the
wealthiest in the united states by far
pay a larger share of their income in
those taxes than do those in lower
income levels so that just doesn't add
up now democrats i think have a big
problem with wealth creation and the
accumulation of wealth
they say that there's a lot of wealthy
people out there who don't earn as much
income but they make a lot of
investments that grow in value over time
they never pay taxes on that and that's
true people hold their investments for
the long term and they they
accumulate the value of those
investments but most people actually
agree that encouraging long-term
investment is a good thing you know it
wasn't that long ago that you found a
lot of democrats crying the
short-termism of markets and the
short-termism of investors and what
they're actually punishing with a wealth
tax is that long-term value creation
investing in something and holding on to
it not selling it
people are certainly
hurting i mean high inflation which of
course republicans say
you know is the result of the
president's policies which he disputes
but it's certainly hurting people
does this put congress under more
pressure
to act on something like a wealth tax
a wealth tax is going to fall on people
who build a business they have a lot of
money invested in that business
but they're not paying
taxes on the value of that business
because they haven't sold it yet right
wealthtax says well you're going to
start paying taxes on the value that
this
well if we do that
how is that going to help that business
grow and hire more people and produce
more
and bring down prices and bring up
people's wages it's not going to so a
wealth tax
is certainly not a cure for inflation
one other thing the president said is
that this is a fiscally responsible plan
because it's going to reduce the deficit
he says over time
but there are significant economic
assumptions built into that right
well he says that this wealth tax is
going to generate 360 billion dollars
over 10 years but again if you look at
the experience of countries that have
tried this in europe they never
ever generated the amount of tax revenue
that they thought they would because the
problem is you've got to value all these
assets that don't have clear values you
know what's the what is the value of my
medium-sized business or the you know
the non-stock investments that don't get
traded on a day-to-day basis somebody's
got to value that and then you've got to
go out there and try to levy the tax on
that and it becomes very very
complicated so
this tax probably isn't going to
generate the 360 billion dollars that he
thinks it will even some supporters of
other parts of the president's plan may
have an issue with targeting unrealized
gains taxing assets that haven't been
sold any time a president puts forth his
budget
it is quote unquote a wish list robert
wolf is a former obama administration
economic advisor founder and ceo of 32
advisors and a fox news contributor it
really depicts
the administration's priorities
and it's a document that then goes
through the congressional cookie cutter
and comes out the other side usually
quite different
so
i would say what he is presenting
some will make it through and some will
not but i do agree
that there should be a minimum tax that
wealthy people pay
and we should reduce and cut a lot of
the loopholes that exist so the
billionaire's tax it's where both on
income
and unrealized gains i.e predominantly
someone's stock holdings like elon musk
which they actually sell them sell but
borrow against
they will be taxed at a minimum 20
percent threshold
on the aggregate amount of income and
unrealized gains
i mean the president's
with higher taxes on the wealthy is that
they
don't pay their fair share
is that somewhat of a false premise
because of their overall share of tax
revenue
so i think you have to separate what
wealthy individuals pay in the aggregate
and what they pay individually
in the aggregate because they are so
wealthy they probably pay
40 percent of all taxes
but if you look on an individual basis
you know most people are paying at their
type of income level a minimum of 28
percent
it's view that many wealthy people if
you include their unrealized gains
actually may be paying less than 10
percent
i mean
i guess when it comes to income tax
that's kind of the strongest part of the
president's argument it would seem
because it's easily understandable to
say hey why is a firefighter or a
teacher
paying a higher rate than billionaires
yeah i have no issue with there being
some sort of minimum income tax on
individuals that make over x amount of
dollars i don't have an issue with that
just like i don't have an issue with a
global minimum tax for corporations
i don't think some of our largest
fortune 100 corporations should be
paying you know 10 when small businesses
are paying north of 30
so i i think there is some things we can
do to make the tax system more fair and
just
but you know this this is something that
is highly unlikely to get passed why do
you say that are there just not enough
democrats on the same page with this
right now while they still have the
majority in congress i mean i think a
few things one a budget doesn't get
passed at a
one-shot basis so everything's going to
be looked at negotiated
my guess is a few things one i don't
think a 5.8 trillion dollar budget will
be approved i don't think a 1.6 trillion
dollars spending package will be
approved and so i think that although
many of the democrats want to change
taxation on wealthy individuals and
corporates i'm not so sure at this point
there are 50 votes to get there
well and even
in the tax the rich debate so to speak
um senators joe manchin and kirsten
cinema two of the democrats who were not
on board with all of buildback better
last year don't seem to be quite on the
same page with each other on this issue
disagreeing on sort of how to achieve
having the wealthy pay more
and so
i guess that's really the kind of tug of
war that you would foresee maybe playing
out more broadly in congress on that
issue
i think that there are a lot of senators
that would not
agree with a 28 tax
i i think they don't want to change the
idea of what income is and versus assets
i think with inflation peaking a lot of
people won't agree with this top line
number so like i said this is the
president's priorities
i think the thing that we should give
president biden credit for
is if you look at the three
real lanes
of this budget one is
it's fiscally responsible you may not
like the idea of two and a half trillion
of dollars of tax increases
but it does reduce the deficit by 1.2
trillion
of which the last administration blew up
the deficit
number two
there's a huge component on what i'll
call national security and safety so
national security i think military is
something like 800 billion so i think
you're going to get a lot of people from
both sides of the aisle support that
especially you know with respect to
what's happening in ukraine and then the
other aspect is safety i mean a lot of
money is going towards community
policing and mental health
so you know there are some things i
think both sides of the aisle will agree
on but once again this will start with
congress more than with the president
in addition to relying on the tax hikes
to
achieve the proposed deficit reduction
though
the president's blueprint also has a
built-in assumption that inflation
really starts to come down so if
inflation keeps running high i mean is
there any chance that this plan
works
so i just want to be clear i don't
believe inflation is transitory i think
the fed has been behind the eight ball
i believe inflation will tail off but i
believe we will have inflation so it may
not stay at seven eight percent
but i think it will stay north of four
percent i'm nervous of supply chain uh
especially with china being shut down
again
i'm nervous with you know a
consumer-driven economy that has still
incredible pent-up demand so
i would be nervous about their analytics
former white house economic advisor and
fox news contributor robert wolf thanks
so much for your time thank you lisa
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary coming up
one of those stories where seemingly
everyone has an opinion or a take on
what it all means will smith slapping
chris rock for making a joke about his
wife's short hair during the oscars
ceremony televised live on abc and
around the world sunday night i love you
g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
keep my wife's name
i'm going to okay well smith has now
publicly apologized to rock and jada
pinkett smith without mentioning the
slap also on instagram writes this is
the season for healing not ready to let
it go just yet three professional
comedians we brought in to talk about it
jimmy fella host of fox cross america on
the radio fox nation host tyrus and ali
breen she's a stand-up comic base in new
york i think the one thing that's weird
about it is we all saw it happen and
nobody reacted like the fact that no
security went up to him just because
he's a famous person
and then afterwards he got to do a
speech and they handed him a weapon
pretty much they were basically hey here
you go if you want to beat the crap out
of more people use this i mean it was
clearly i think will smith was wrong but
to say that he was like this maniac is a
little bit much i mean i guess that's
the reason there was no security is they
realized it was going to be contained
well that's another that's another facet
of this
is it's fame and privilege and all that
if
anybody in the fourth row back isn't
going to get to run on stage and not get
kicked out of the building will smith
got to do it because he's will smith
yeah it actually says that on the seats
it's like you're in the kicked out
section if you
yeah you guys feel free to assault other
assault rose yeah um is it an antiquated
notion the idea of defending your wife
like that um
is it should jada be jada can take care
of herself why is will gotta go up there
and smack that that's and that's another
one of the um things floating around
that's super antiquated and she wasn't
her feelings got hurt that's all that
happened it wasn't anything that was
really that malicious she was compared
to another hot
you know sexy rich woman it's crazy
again uh it's it's different because
people are kind of conflating this with
like defending your wife's honor on the
street like someone comes up throws a
drink on your wife or calls her a [ __ ]
or something crazy yeah this is actually
at a comedy show ty i wanted to ask you
this do you think on some level because
it's about more of a guy thing
knowing that his wife is like pretty
open about the fact that she's sleeping
with everyone in hollywood but him do
you think in that moment he's defending
his own honor and not hers because it's
one more slight for him to endure he was
smacking her i mean
angry yeah he laughed at the joke yes
thank you
yeah the reason i was watching is i
enjoy white people talking about two
brothers hitting each other and how
comfortable you are with it because if
chris walk would have been robin
williams let's see
and he smacked him this would be a very
different conversation this wouldn't
even be on a comedy show well there
would be heads of of everybody that it'd
be every serious news how can this go
along this and he needs to be arrested
but let me just jump
hold on a second because robin williams
has gotten hit for stealing jokes but
yeah that's different they're all rich
and privileged the
race has nothing to do with this okay
you guys would have been completely
talking about this different if you
would hit somebody outside the box what
do you mean like outside of the show you
can have physical combat with your own
box and everyone thinks it's fine
but if he would have been anything else
anything out of the box society would
have been
lost their mind
protest outside he's ready
would you have smacked amy if it was
male and female that would have been a
problem people would have gotten
arrested immediately if it was black and
white if it was another white i mean
chris rock is as famous as any other any
any any famous person out there
i think it's 100 that's all that it has
no i think but what he's saying is that
we are are you saying that we've been
going either way yeah because it's it
was it was a safe hit it was a straight
brother and a straight brother
there's no group that can benefit from
it because we don't protest when we get
hit we usually say i'll holler at you
outside chris was phenomenal in the fact
he knew that he knew it was coming yeah
that's why he kept his hands behind his
back because he had more to lose than
will did he has to finish the show but
don't you think he thought that it was
going to be a jokes like no
he thought that was real he knew you
think he knew yeah some guys have
nervous laughs and then chris rock has a
nervous laugh and he knew when he got up
it wasn't like will got up smiling yeah
he watched the camera goes off them
chris tries to settle it down already
goes that was nice yeah yeah there was
an exchange going on between will and
his wife yeah yeah when the camera went
back to chris yeah because he laughed
she made the face he looked at her and
said you're not gonna do anything about
this and this is when the the
dysfunctional relationship that everyone
has been with at one time or another you
go out to a bar you're at a nice dinner
and the waiter does something wrong and
you don't think it's that big of a deal
and then she looks at you and says you
don't do anything about it
and then yeah no but that's what happens
at a bar some guy hits on her yeah he's
gonna let that go yeah yeah that type of
man you are uh-huh he doesn't want and
then he goes hits the guys
that's why i talked about the show this
has to do with their dysfunction
relationship and this is what men
unfortunately do to try to fix things
instead of going it was funny get over
yourself this is my night no it is now
her night yeah it's ruined and he
because he and he threw away
everything that he stood for i
understand and
growing up he was one that was talk [ __ ]
about all the time because he wouldn't
cuss in his raps he was the fresh
principal he did it the right way he was
about as vanilla ice cream as a brother
can be in entertainment and still be
successful yeah like he wasn't doing
kids shows but he was the guy they were
like that's who i want my son to be well
look in bed
so this guy spent 30 plus years
cultivating this image one of the
biggest stars in the world like you said
uh almost universally beloved and then
poof
nobody is he's ever gonna watch might as
well have been a backup singer for nwa
yeah don't screw it all the way nobody
is ever going to watch the fresh picture
bel-air nobody's ever going to watch
anything in the past or in the future in
the same way just watch the new one
differently like ah it's more like the
new one
i think we have a really short memory
and we'll actually move on in some
capacity
is this gonna be a problem at comedy
clubs i know that there are a few comics
have said oh no i can't do crowd work
anymore because somebody's gonna be
emboldened by will smith yeah to jump up
on the stage absolutely beginning the
green light he green line at it yeah
it's going to happen
you know
i mean only for crazy people i don't
think there's going to be a huge swarm
of people looking to create violence but
anyone who is already the scenario he
just described though what tyrus
described earlier if a guy tells a joke
about a girl and they're in a toxic
not to mention you're going to get a lot
of publicity so before it was like
instead of hanging off a cliff to take a
selfie on instagram now it's smack a
comic yeah and it'll be how you know he
did this and that especially you know
for conservative comics yeah you're
going to see you're going to see a lot
of justifiable attempts to yeah just you
know hopefully and one side will rally
behind it there really will be people
who are like no that was that the nice
thing though for conservative comics is
everybody who supports us is armed at
all times
what's more likely will smith and chris
rock doing the super bowl commercial
next year or presenting at the oscars
next year both both
both
i
and of course chris was the bigger man
he didn't press charges yeah he didn't
even talk he hasn't really talked
although you know judge jeanine was
saying he didn't have to yeah because
there was enough witnesses um but i i
think this i think will's going to go
away for a while yeah and he should
rightfully shouldn't no not just do you
think he'll be forced to or you think
he'll choose i mean he makes his own
movies anyways so he's his own producer
so it's not like he's waiting for a call
from miramax you know what i'm saying
like he produces his own stuff but uh
hopefully if there's i mean he's an
intelligent man
hopefully he realizes that he needs some
help same question that we asked about
will smith
is there an asterisk on on chris rock's
work now is no
is he going to be at least on some level
in the back of people's mind the guy
that gets smacked
people who have never been in a fight
before or lived behind a a little
keyboard they'll talk about what they
would have done yeah but what he chose
to he put the academy
and his job over his personal safety
back for a reason yeah and he even
caught himself because he was about to
change he was about to rip him when he
talked about the table yeah he started
saying i couldn't say that and he caught
himself he did and he
there was a second one and this one was
not going to be kind no because being
referred to as a jacked woman with bald
head kicking ass and men's in the men's
military at the time is not an insult
that was also a a bed-stuy broken move
of rock not to even touch his face yeah
he didn't rub it no didn't take a step
back now he was doing that you could
tell he was hurt but he was not doing it
wrestling he didn't sell it
yeah and what does that say about will
smith's ability to portray muhammad ali
that he couldn't even you know
130 pound comedian the oscars slap comes
less than a year after chris rock said
cancel culture is making comedy boring
leading to unfunny comedians and unfunny
award shows calling it bizarre
especially in america back to jimmy
fayla chris rock his last special was
written by michelle wolf like he does
hang out with a little more of uh
these days like the enlightened comedic
side of town and wants to be on the
right side of that
and i think is mindful of the fact that
you know people are offended by the
alopecia joke not that it was an
alopecia joke because he didn't know but
he doesn't want to be in his social
circle seen as punching down and this is
the what's wrong with comedy nowadays
people who make the rules for comedy
don't do comedy nobody in a comedy club
reads the room we lead the room we're
the only ones with a microphone we set
the terms of the negotiation we don't
read the room and nobody worries about
punching down that's something people
tacked on in the blogosphere to make
rules for comedians that like this will
be how we grade them and hold them to
our standard but if you're a real comic
you just throw the fastball and that's
what chris rock did in that moment uh
will smith overreacted i mean and this
is the byproduct of two things what tyra
said which is a toxic relationship but
also we've had five years of people
treating jokes as hate crimes this is
why you have to defund the joke police
because there's a lot of people out
there who cannot distinguish between
someone making fun of you and literally
attacking you well thank you for coming
on i think i feel like we didn't have
too much time left to get the hot takes
out there before they're all hot tooken
ali brain with
gilbert gottfried this weekend at
magooby's yes in lutherville maryland
yep okay yeah this weekend uh jimmy
fallon fox across america weekdays on
the radio tyrus on fox nation podcast
hyrus and temp you got a book coming out
next month yep just tyrus it drops uh
april 26th congratulations thanks guys
awesome thanks
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind in a recent rally
russia celebrated the eight-year
anniversary of the annexation of crimea
during the spectacle russian dictator
vladimir putin quoted an unlikely source
the bible he spoke about the bravery and
unity of russia's troops during the
so-called military operation
in reality a needless war that putin
started in ukraine which has left
thousands of innocent civilians dead and
displaced over 10 million people
putin invoked the words of jesus from
john 15 13 to describe his soldiers
actions
jesus said greater love has no one than
this
that someone laid down his life for his
friends
the irony here is thick
jesus spoke these words to his disciples
on the eve of his own crucifixion
jesus was speaking about himself about
his own willingness to suffer and die
innocently for the sake of others
john 15 13 is the ultimate statement of
self-sacrifice and love
putin is the absolute antithesis of what
christ models in this passage
instead of sacrificing himself for
others putin sacrifices others for
himself putin has sent thousands of
russian boys into a war with no purpose
to fight and die in an unjust battle
against innocent people
putin seeks his own deluded version of
personal and national glory he has shown
that he will bomb however many ukrainian
apartment complexes and churches and
hospitals he has to bomb in order to
achieve his vision
he will tell whatever lies he has to
tell he will silence and murder whomever
he has to silence and murder
putin knows nothing about the way of
jesus or self-sacrifice
quoting god's word to justify something
god would never condone is a very old
strategy
christ's words are being twisted into
pathetic strange justifications for
putin's evil
putin is doing everything possible to
distract from the realities caused by
his callous disregard for human life
if mr putin is interested in thinking
biblically there are a few other verses
he may want to consider
for example god told moses and etched
into stone by his own hand the
commandment you shall not murder
at the end of history vladimir putin
will not be the ruler of this world he
won't be sitting on a throne
instead putin will be bending his knee
and preparing to answer to the king
whose words he has perverted to justify
evil
this is robert jeffress for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download listen and be inspired with
lauren green's lighthouse faith fox news
religion correspondent lauren green uses
her wealth of stories to take the
listener on a unique journey of
spiritual discovery subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com